hi there steve kaufman here again i
haven't done a video in quite a while um
i thought i would report back on my
trip to europe and uh you may remember
that uh one of the main
goals was to spend some time in prague
and i had announced my strategy of five
days to fluency
the idea being that i would set myself
this goal of uh going to where the
language was spoken i was studying czech
and i would prepare for it and i would
build up to it and that i would have
this tremendous passive knowledge of the
language and when i got there
within five days following on the advice
of dr hooligan off within three days my
passive knowledge would become active
and uh
so what was the result
well i would say that after five days in
prague i did not become fluent in
check
however
i consider the whole experiment to be
tremendously successful
it's successful because of the way it's
structured i set myself a goal i'm going
to go somewhere in a year
i study towards that goal as i come
closer to the data i study even harder
and when i go there and and this was my
experience in prague i was able to
understand everything i felt comfortable
i was able to talk to people i had it
set up so that i was speaking seven six
seven eight hours a day of check
and certainly uh my check in improved
tremendously
my comprehension improved my my ability
to read i'm reading novels now with more
comfort
than i had before the whole czech
language thing has become more real to
me
uh the final evening in prague i had a
an evening with a couple that invited me
to dinner and we spoke entirely in check
and i was quite comfortable i could
understand everything they were saying i
was able to get my meaning across
so all of that was good
however i don't think i achieved fluency
um
i still stumble
and i did a sort of a
video with yarda but unfortunately the
sound is so low that i can't use it
and so what i'm going to do is perhaps
next week i'm going to have a discussion
with a tutor maybe yarda maybe someone
else and try to record it so you can see
just exactly what the state of my check
is
um
unfortunately after my it's actually
four days in prague
i then had not unfortunately but
unfortunately for my check
i had
three weeks
in portugal spain and then three days in
berlin so essentially
for almost
a month now i have not been using my
check
and on top of that i've decided that i
should really do something about my
korean
so i have now this week started up
studying korean again
so
i'm trying to maintain my check
i try to read something or listen to
something every day and check i'm still
trying to maintain my russian because
the influence of check on my russian was
to kind
of uh caused me to stumble a lot more
when speaking russian
and of course when i was in germany i
was so motivated to improve my german
that i figured i should do more with
german because we had a
meet-up with our
members in berlin and i i guess i really
had trouble
expressing myself as well as i would
like to express myself in german
and so i think my german has fallen
quite a bit
so going forward here i'm going to be
trying to really focus on korean with
the idea of going to korea and doing
another five days to fluency
test just to see how far i can push
myself with this objective of going
there
five days is not enough so hopefully
i'll get myself a little longer
uh but at the main in the meantime i
also want to maintain my uh check in
russian and german so we'll see how it
goes
um
one other thing i should report back on
was this conference at berlin called
spochan
they translated that as language and
business
i went there in the hope that i could
interest someone there
in link
you know
corporate language training people
unfortunately the conference was was
well attended by teachers and coaches
and trainers and academics
but there was there were hardly any
representatives there
from corporations in other words the
potential clients for these people
offering these language training
services
so that was a bit of a disappointment
there were a number of presentations
some were better than others
number of themes that would come up
quite uh quite often one was this idea
this this concern about intercultural
communication because more and more
companies are hiring people of different
language backgrounds and within europe
you have different working groups within
multinational corporations where people
have to work across language and
cultural barriers and so there's a
concern that people need to be trained
in in how to deal with people of
different language and cultural
backgrounds even though everyone is
speaking english typically
i am a little bit skeptical about how
much you can teach
these cultural skills
uh in my experience in japan i have
found that people who are sincere
and
respected other people
and
performed
in terms of their business dealings they
managed to do well
and that these sort of pre-packaged
stereotypes about different cultures
were of limited use the number of useful
bits of advice
is quite limited
and there is a danger that you treat
people as sort of simply tokens of some
culture and therefore people who must
conform to a certain stereotype rather
than dealing with them as individuals
personally i think a better way to
understand people of different cultures
is to try to learn their language
and learn about their history and stuff
and these are things we have to do on
our own i'm not
quite sure how effective these uh
cultural trainers are
another thing that came up at the
conference was this idea of english as a
lingua franca the idea being there that
since
a majority of english speakers are not
native speakers we should be teaching
english differently
than we teach other languages that the
native speaker is not necessarily the
model and also that in a group where
people speak english at different levels
of competence first of all the native
speaker has a big advantage in these
multinational corporations but also
people who speak english well have an
advantage over people who don't speak
well so we should learn how to
communicate
in a way that makes everybody happy and
comfortable again maybe it's a nice idea
but i don't know how practical that is
obviously the better you speak the
language the greater advantage you're
going to have i don't think it's
necessarily a good idea to talk down to
people
i'm just going to see
yeah just hold on a sec here
hello
hi
hi
i yeah i'm in the middle of doing a
video right now
can i call you in 10 minutes
okay
bye
yeah rather than starting all over again
so yeah english is a
language lingua franca is kind of a new
way of teaching english
uh
you know they gave some examples that
you know in britain if they say you know
we're on a sticky wicket that people
don't know what that means but those
things are not that common i think most
people learning a language
even though the teacher may not be a
native speaker and needn't be a native
speaker the model of the language is
typically the language as spoken by a
native speaker
and we can decide whether we prefer to
learn
the french that's spoken in quebec or in
southern france or in i don't know north
africa or paris
uh or the english is spoken in australia
or spoken in south africa or india
whichever we find the most useful but
we're still going to imitate native
speakers basically so i think the model
is still a native speaker and i'm not
sure that teaching people to talk down
to other people is all that useful maybe
i'm a bit cynical here but i didn't see
that as all that useful
uh some of the other themes there were
someone suggested that really the skills
that are required now are either very
low skills for the hospitality uh
industry like uh
a1a2 on the european scale or very
advanced language skills for
professionals
and my feeling there again was that i
wouldn't want to deal with a hotel clerk
who only had a1 or a2 in in english i
think
as we learned we just continued to
improve and i think most people are
going to end up in the in the b in the
sort of intermediate category
and um
i'm also of the mind that training
people for specific
uh
jobs and the specific job vocabulary
is not always the best policy i think
it's better to give people an overall
grounding in the language and then let
them focus on things that are of of
interest to them where the you know the
vocabulary is relevant but you still
need a pretty sound basis in the
language so
um
yeah so i guess i had the impression
that that um yeah one other thing that
came up too was this idea that it's not
what you know but what it's what you can
do in the language that matters and so
again there were many examples of
teachers explaining what they did to get
people to use the language
the idea that you have to use it or you
don't have it and and as some of you may
know i really think there's tremendous
value in acquiring
a passive
capability in the language this the
ability to understand vocabulary that
that builds up your potential it gives
you a strong base rather than trying at
an early stage to to say a few things
uh which may only trigger a fluent
response from someone else and then
you're hopelessly lost
uh so uh you know i came away from the
conference thinking that it's
understandable if you're running a
classroom that you need to have certain
activities and that the goal is going to
try to get people to to say things and
do things and you're going to try to
target
uh specific you know maybe job-related
subject matter and have role-playing and
stuff like that but
for me as an independent learner someone
who learns for fun
i'll stick with the way i like to learn
but you know nothing wrong with the way
other people like to learn and that's
why getting back to my prague experience
i didn't become fluent but i consider
the whole thing a success because i feel
tremendously satisfied at what i am able
to do in czech or in the other languages
and i think that's the important thing
however we choose to learn whatever we
like to do
we should regularly give ourselves
credit for what we have achieved and we
should do the things that we like to do
because that ensures that we stay with
it
and if we stay with it
uh and if you have a good attitude and
if we learn to notice the language those
are the big three keys from
that lady at san diego state university
we are going to do well
we're going to do well not only by our
own standards but by the standards of
other people
so there you have it just a brief
summary of my trip to europe and i hope
to start you know getting back to doing
these videos more regularly thanks for
listening bye for now